so LeBron James and his best friend
maverick Carter just raised a hundred
million dollars to start a new black
media company unapologetic black media
company called spring kill by the way
brilliant move and brilliant timing on
LeBron James and maverick Carter to do
it now because they kind of looked at
Robert Johnson founder bTW he's worth
around six hundred dollars today LeBrons
worth about 480 starting a media company
at a time like this this could turn into
something really really big because if
we were to talk about a black media
company today that reports on the news
who are you gonna think about there's
nothing to be thinking about genius
right there so LeBron James if we were
to assess his next five moves what's he
thinking about whose playbook did he
take well I'm gonna go be the greatest
basketball player of all time Michael
did this he wanted on the team Kobe's
doing his magic did this maybe I'm gonna
take a little bit from this he took a
little bit about from Trump on how Trump
becomes a president because media little
bit from Bloomberg because Bloomberg own
a media company to take his rock so
could there be that LeBrons next five
moves maybe at 18 years old he's coming
out saying I'm gonna go out there and be
one of the greatest basketball players
of all time if not the greatest okay
he's gonna score the most points he's
gonna be the first basketball player
ever to play on the same team with a son
what if that happens with him and brawny
history 40,000 points maybe when a chip
or two with the Lakers maybe get your
five so number one move that he had was
be the greatest basketball player of all
time which that gives you a bigger
platform you can't become LeBron James
if you're not the greatest at what
you're doing
he did that number two what's his next
move after basketball well maybe we
start a media company while I'm going
about basketball check he just did that
number three after I leave the NBA maybe
I buy a basketball team similar to what
Mike did check he's gonna do that then
I'm gonna be a billionaire but not just
to be a billionaire because I want to go
play sports but because I'm gonna be a
billionaire to have that money and be
able to use it to do something bigger
which could lead to what could LeBron
James end up wanting to run for office
one day
I don't know I'm speculating but if
LeBron James had his five moves in place
those may be some of the things that
he's known so now your next five moves
that's what bran James right we can look
a lot of different people's five moves
and kind of go through their career
whether it's President Barack Obama or
Trump or musk or Bezos or ZUP or a lot
of these guys but what are your next
five months so for me a lot of people
ask me to say Pat I know you're ripped
or you wrote this book called your next
five moves I can't wait to get a copy of
it but what should my next five moves be
what should I be doing you may be
somebody that's not fully clear on what
you want to be doing what should your
next five moves be right off the bat I
can give you a simple playbook right
after that move number one study
industries and choose one listen LeBron
chose one industry which is what
basketball Trump chose one industry
which is what real estate okay Zach
choose one industry all of these rock
chose one industries going in and then
from that industry in wrestling he
expanded into movies then movies is
expanding so he started our football
Miami Hurricanes then wrestling both
wider then boom movies wider but you
choose one industry at first to become
the best at then you have a lot of
opportunities LeBron is basketball
Trump's real estate
what's yours choose one industry second
thing you do once you choose the
industry is who is the best person in
that industry for you to go work with
closely so you can learn every single
thing this person is doing in that
industry so you go work for them if you
can or you go study the best ones if you
can so those are the second move that
you have what's your third one when you
work with this person that's the best in
the industry guess what you do become so
valuable for them become so valuable to
them do whatever you can to help them
out whatever you can bring so many
different opportunities for this person
and help them advance because what's
your move number four move number four
is one or two things gonna happen with
you when that person leaves you can
replace them or when you're moving up
you can ask that person and say listen I
know you got a lot of things going on
right now help me let me run this
company for you let me run this business
for you running five companies let me
run one of them
let me get equity here but that person
is gonna look at and you're gonna be the
most trusted advisor and an insider
royal person like you a lot of
opportunities are gonna come your way
and if it doesn't come your way guess
what you do at that time go start your
own deal that's the simple playbook of
five
choose an industry go partner with the
best person in the marketplace become so
valuable to them ask to run one of their
companies or on equity and if they say
no you go start your own company that's
a simple next five moves by the way
there's five moves for college graduate
there's five moves before you get
married there's five months for
parenting there's five moves for
development leaders everything is about
your next five moves so today I shared
with you potentially LeBrons next five
moves again I'm speculating then I
shared with you what I would be doing if
I'm you at some point saying I want to
go do something big with my life that's
your next five moves but all of that is
why I wrote this book your next five
moves and the book comes out August 18
which is a few weeks from now but prior
to the book coming out I'm giving away a
chapter to anybody who goes out there
and purchases a book if you haven't yet
gone that chapter to read it's one of
the best chapters in the book you can
either click on a link below in the
description or you can go to your next
five moves com to see the ideas of what
things different things you can do one
if you buy copy we send you chapter if
you buy three copies to give away as a
gift I send a one our strategy session
over to you with four different
quadrants of exactly what I would be
doing to come up with my next five moves
and then that video will be sent over to
you if you purchase a three books so
again you can either go on the link
below or go to your next five moves com
or you can text next move to three one
zero three four zero one one three two
once again three one zero three four
zero one one three two with the number
name next move and we'll send you the
link for you to order the copy and if
you've not subscribed to this channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody
take care bye bye